i have a beef uh something that i want
to complain about
um
i've noticed lately and i don't know if
it bothers anybody else but i'm noticing
lately that a celebrity will pass away
and the celebrity will be quite old
someone who's an icon yeah and this has
happened two or three times in the last
two weeks and not i'm not gonna bum
people out by naming specific names but
someone will die at
you know
in their 90s and
they're a star of stage and screen and
they've been and then a couple of days
later there'll be an article that
reveals their cause of death and i'm
like oh who needs that anymore i think
you know what i mean it's just it just
well what do you mean i'm not curious it
just i think when someone is 98
you don't have to say well
here's what happened
well i mean unless it's spicy yeah
unless it's no but it's not spicy shot
robbing a bank i know but that's what i
was going to say that that that i keep
reading these venerable people who were
in their late 90s close to 100 are
passing away
and it's you know oh wow we should take
a moment we should really think about
these people these are great people and
you feel the sadness of their passing
but i don't then need an article a
couple of days later that says all right
you ready for this
we've
we figured it out like we don't need to
figure it out and it reminds me of
the time
jack klugman passed away and jack
klugman had been
uh you know great actor of course many
people know him from the tv show the odd
couple but he had famously like
you know i i think lived a full life and
he had had a lot of bouts with different
diseases and cancer he's a big i think
he's a big smoker and and anyway but he
beat it all and and then finally at a
very advanced stage he finally succumbed
you know and passed away but this is
after you thought he was very sick like
20 years earlier but still kept you know
and he finally passed away and so i'm
talking to my brother neil on the phone
and i said uh
to neil
oh i just oh i just see it right here on
the background it's um it's on the tv
that jack klugman died
my brother neal said what happened
what happened
well neil he he built a rocket
uh-huh and he strapped himself to it and
tried to go to the moon and it blew up
what do you mean what happened so i want
i don't know what my fate is none of us
really know sony you probably know cause
he probably hired someone to kill me but
yeah you know exactly what's gonna
happen to me but yes but i don't think
we need a national investigation
if if i make it past i just want there
to be if i make it past 95.
95. so if you if you pass it 94 you want
people to know to know how if 94 i want
there to be a thorough investigation
i want an autopsy and i want everyone
around me arrested and held for
questioning what if yes 94 if i go at 94
i want everyone around me immediately
apprehended and questioned and body
searches cavity searches oh man i want
everyone to check cameras but at 90 from
95 on yeah i want people just to um
toss me out the nearest window what if
it's funny like what if you what if you
pass away like on the toilet and it's
you know it's funny and you know people
will think it's funny i mean we have i
don't know
i don't find that toilet i don't like
toilet humor and so i would ask that
that be kept quiet i think if i'm
you know riding a super fast motorcycle
at 95
and i crash uh i crash
into a ferris wheel and
i get tangled up with the ferris wheel
and my
my my bleeding body that's also on fire
is going in a big circle on the ferris
wheel
and
a crowd gathers and people just start
roasting marshmallows
and every time that the the wheel gets
lowered down they all rush forward and
put their marshmallows out but then as
the as the wheel lifts
they retreat
and the guy who operates the isn't there
the guy who operates the service wheel
isn't there and there's just a sign that
says back in two days
yeah he's on a break for two days jesus
um then
that's funny to me
how's that gonna work cause of death and
then like a two paragraph
explanation you know what's gonna say
it's gonna say the coroner did a
thorough investigation
mr o'brien's rocket sled uh
motorcycle
struck the ferris wheel at approximately
140 miles an hour
um mr o'brien mr o'brien was not killed
by the impact
miraculously he was uh wearing well
armored motorcycle gear
um he crumpled uh he caught fire
but according to everything eyewitnesses
say he shrieked and screamed like a
monkey
for two days for for quite a while in
the ferris wheel
um he was alive but the attendant had
been had left and was and was missing um
and no one could stop the ferris wheel
not because they didn't know how to but
it's a union thing no one was allowed to
approach the lever and uh mr o'brien's
flaming corpse
flaming body he shrieked and screamed
for a day and a half but the coroner
says that he died of dehydration
if someone had at least given him a sip
of water he'd be alive today to tell the
story
conan o'brien gone at 95 from a
jet motorcycle crash
into a ferris wheel and subsequent
marshmallow cookout
an epidemic that's sweeping the nation
then
then neil can call up and go what
happened
that would make sense